[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
وهذه هي العربيه
دي حريفك
المستوطنات وهدم البيوت
[تصفيق]
في ايران وبعد ملاحقه لرجال الدين الامن
يكثف انتشاره بزهدان مع تصاعدي غضب
المحتجين
عشرات الاف الموظفين المانيا تفتح الباب
لهم وتعرض توظيفهم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام اذا في التفاصيل
نبدا بالاخبار العاجله قبل دخول بملفات
العربيه 360 نتوقف مع هذه الاخبار العاجله
عن اصابه مستوطنين اذا في هجوم بالدهس في
الضفه الغربيه
اخر الانباء من هناك وهذه الصور التي
وصلتنا وهي صور اوليه لمكان الحادث او
العمليه يعني حتى الان طاهر لا معلومات عن
منفذ هذه العمليه ان كان فرر ام تم القاء
القبض عليه ولكن هذه الصور التي وردتنا
بشكل اولي تتحدث عن اصابه مستوطنين اثنين
شمالي الضفه الغربيه طبعا تتزامن هذه
الحادثه مع زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الى رام الله وقبلها الى تل ابيب لتهدئه
الوضع بعد ما حصل
بمخيم جنين ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الحفيظ
جعوان اهلا بك عبد الحفيظ من رام الله ما
اخر المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان حول هذه
العمليه او حادثه الدحس
اء الاعلام الاسرائيليه فان سائق شاحنه
فلسطين متوسطه الحجم قد قام بدحس اثنين لا
نعرف ان كانوا مستوطنين ام ام جنديين
واعلى ما يبدو ان احدهم اصيب بجراح خطيره
وتقوم الان مروحيه بنقله للاسعاف وتمكن
المهاجم من الفرار من منطقه الحاج الزعتر
والجنوب مدينه نابلس اذكر همم مصادر امنيه
اسرائيليه تقول انه فر باتجاه الجنوب
باتجاه مدينه رام الله والقرى المحاضيه
وعمليات ال- همم المداهمه والتفتيش
تجريحات هذه اللحظه هذه التفاصيل المتوفره
حتى هذه اللحظه عن هذا الهجوم همم تبقى
معنا عبد الحفيظ العوان ونشاهد المزيد من
هذه الصور التي تصلنا لمكان هذه العمليه
وكما افادنا قبل قليل اذنا عبد الحفيظ
باصابه المستوطنين في حادث الدهس عند
زعتره وحاجه زعتر تحديدا همم والمصادر
العسكريه كانت تحدث عن ان حادث دهس عند
هذا الحاجز قد يكون
متعمدا همم كيف يمكن ان يعني نعرف اكثر عن
حجم الاجراءات الامنيه التي اتخذت في هذا
المكان وفي محيطها او في بقيه المناطق على
اثره عبد الحفيظ
ام طاهر هناك اصلا انتشار اسرائيلي كثير
منذ ثلاثه او اربعه ايام اعلنت اسرائيل
على النشر ثلاثه كتائب اضافيه في الضفه
الغربيه وبالتالي هناك تجديد كبير على
الحواجز الاسرائيليه وهناك ايضا انتشار
كبير للمستوطنين وتحديدا قرب حاج الزعتر
وعلى حاجز الزعتره يعني عشرات عمليات
الاعتداءات التي نفذها المستوطنون على همم
مركبات الفلسطينيين وبالتالي حتى موضوع
حادثه لا نعرف يعني همم طبيعه هذا هذا
ربما يكون احد الفلسطينيين حاول القرار من
المستوطنين وحدث ذلك بالمناسبه قبل يوم
واحد قبل يومين عند حجز حواره القريب
عندما يعني اطلقت الجنود الاسرائيليون
النار على سائق فلسطيني ايضا عندما حاول
الفرار من المستوطنين الذين كانوا يلقون
الحجاره على مركبات الفلسطينيين وبالتالي
طبيعه هذا الهجوم حتى الان غير واضحه ايضا
كما تشاهد يعني الجو ضباب ومطر والشوارع
زلقه للغايه وبالتالي
الموضوع ليس عمليه متعمده وان مرضت فعل
همم فلسطيني على التعرض لهم من قبل
المستوطنين
نعم هذا وارد هذا وارد بشكل كبير عشرات
العمليات التي تصنف على انها عمليات دعسه
وعمليات هجوم تكون اساسا حوادث سير وحدثت
قبل ذلك بان يعني اطلقت قوات الاسرائيليه
النار على سائق مركبات فلسطينيه بسبب
حوادث سير او حاله ارتباك نظرا للتجديدات
العسكريه الكبيره والنظارادي الكبير
للمستوطنين همم ننتظر التفاصيل الاضافيه
حول هذا الحديث لنعرف
ايضا همم مرشح لمثل هذه العمليات في خصوصا
في ظل هذه الايام تقول القوات الاسرائيليه
ان هناك عشرات لانذارات بنيه فلسطينيين
تنفيذ عمليات فرديه من هذا القبيل سواء
عمليات بس او عمليات الطعام
عبد الحفيظ في حال ورود اي معلومات اضافيه
حول حادث الدهس الذي ربما مثل ماذا كانت
هي ربما لا يكون متعمدا شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
المره من الله عبد الحفيظ
[موسيقى]
خطاب باللغه السلام توجه به وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه في رام الله قائلا من
الفلسطينيين يواجهون تداولا في افاق الامل
كرر معارضه الولايات المتحده لتوسيع
اسرائيل في الاستيطانه بينما دعائي الى
تهدئه التوتر بعد تفاقم العنف في الضفه
الغربيه
بمدينه رام الله قدمت عزيزه لمقتل
فلسطينيين ابرياء قائلا يسمحوا لي ان ابدا
بالاعراب عن تعازينا وحزننا على مقتل
المدنيين الفلسطينيين الابرياء الذين فق
ارواحهم في تصعيد العنف خلال العام الماضي
الولايات المتحده عظمه على العمل مع
شركائها لتعزيز بيئه اكثر استقرارا وايجاد
حلول الوسطى للخروج من دوامه العنف
واستثناء في محادثه السلام بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وطلبنا كافه
الاطراف بخفضه
عميقه بين الاطراف الفلسطينيه
والاسرائيليه ايذاء المسار الراهن في
البلاد
اقراص ايميل
خلال الاجتماع
الاسرائيليه والسلطه الفلسطينيه
قالت مصادره للعربيه ان القياده
الفلسطينيه سلمت وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ورقه من اثني عشر بندا هذه البنود تخص
الاجراءات احاديه الجانب التي تقوم بها
اسرائيل وقضايا الوضع النهائي
بان تجبر اسرائيل على الالتزام بها كشرط
لاعاده التنسيق معها وعوده الهدوء تمهيدا
لاي مفاوضات محتمله
الزيارات الامريكيه الى رام الله هذا
الشهر بداها مستشار الامن القومي ثم مديره
وكاله الاستخبارات السياسيه
من الفلسطينيين هو التهدئه والثمن وعد
بالحفاظ على مبدا يحل الدولتين واعاده فتح
القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه و 50
مليون دولار الى جانب توفير خدمه الجيل
الرابع للانترنت وغيرها
في هذه الاسماء نحن نعرض اي اجراء من جانب
اي طرف لجعل لحل الدولتين صعب المنال ونحن
كنا واضحين ان هذا يشمل اجراءات كتوسيع
المستوطنات وتشريع البؤري الاستيطانيه
واعمال هدم البيوت واخلاء المنازل من
سكانها وتغيير الوضع القائم التاريخي في
الاماكن المقدسه
الوعود والزيارات الامريكيه لرام الله
تبدو مرضيه نوعا مال السلطه الفلسطينيه
بعد قطيعه اداره ترامب لكن اليست كافيه
فيرىى الفلسطينيون ضروره ان تترجم الى
خطوات عمليه على الارض لعوده المسار
التفاوضطي لذلك سلموا لاداره الامريكيه
ورقه من 12 بندا ابرازها ان تتوقف اسرائيل
عن اقتحام المدن وتوسيع المستوطنات وتغيير
الوضع التاريخي والديني في القدس
للعمل مع الاداره
الامريكي المجتمع الدولي لعوده الحوار
للشيخ
من اجل انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عمليه من جانب الاداره الامريكيه لتنفيذ
ايلتزام من هذه الالتزامات منذ تسلم هذه
الاداره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه طلب من
القياده الفلسطينيه اعاده التنسيق الامني
مع اسرائيل والحد من انتشار المجموعات
المسلحه وبسط السيطره الامنيه والمضيء
بالاصلاحات القانونيه نتائج زياره بلنكن
للمنطقه ستظهر بعد انتهائها مباشره ان
كانت اسرائيل ستوقف اقتحامات المدن وبناء
المستوطنات وهدم المنازل ام ان وزراء
حكومه نتنياهو من اليمين المتطرف سيواصلون
مغامره تكون نتائجها دمويه كما حدث في
الشهر الاول من هذا العام عبد الحفيظ
جعوان العربيه على اراضي الفلسطينيه
يبقى معنا مراسل العربيه عبد الحفيظ جعوان
من رام الله ليطلعنا على يعني اي معلومات
توفرت بعد اعدادك لهذا التقرير ربما
فيما يتعلق بهذه البنود التي تحدثنا عنها
لا معلومات كثيره طاهر سوى يعني الاحباط
من الجانب الفلسطيني وعدم التفاؤل تحدثنا
مع اكثر من من جانب فلسطيني مع اكثر من
شخص من الذين شاركوا في الاجتماع وقالوا
لم نسمع اي كلمه جديده في همم حديث وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي كلها وعود ولم نرى شيء
يطبق على الارض حتى هذه اللحظه ولا
يعتقدون اصلا ان الاداره الامريكيه قادره
على اجبار الحكومه الاسرائيليه همم ذات
التركيبه المعقده التي فيها وزراء من
اليمين المتطرف ومن الصهيونيه ومن
الصهيونيه الدينيه لا يعتقدون ان الحكومه
الامريكيه يمكن ان تغير من توجهه هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي الكل ينتظر
يعني حال ان تقطع طائره بن تن البحر ما
الذي سيجري هنا في الضفه الغربيه هناك همم
مدينه اريحا ريحه مثلا محاصره بالكامل
وهنا كانت تحضيرات
باقتحامها واقتحام مخيم عقبه جبر هناك
ايضا موضوع الهدم همم
انه احد اليوم اصدر التصريحا قال هدمت
سبعه بيوت في القدس وهناك سبعه بيوت اخرات
سوف اقوم بحدمهم وهناك مواجهات الان في
جبل المكبر في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي الكل
غير متفائل على الجانب الفلسطيني ياملون
يعملون بان يتمكن الاداره الامريكيه من
الضغط على نتنياهو وكان نتنياهو بالفعل
يعني شاهدنا تراجع للعمليات العسكريه
وعمليات الاعتقال خلال اليومين الماضيين
يقولون امل ان تكون هذه السياسه ولكن
يعتقدون انها مجرد مجامله من نتنياهو
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي وربما تنقلب
الامور راسا على عقب فور خروجهم من
المتحده
المستوى الشعب عبد الحفيظ يعني المستوى
الرسمي ربما غير متفائل ولكن لسان حال
المواطن الفلسطيني بعد ما حصل مؤخرا ماذا
يقول يعني هل هو متفائل هل من امل
ايضا يعني الاحباط على مستوى الشارع بشكل
عام وهم يشاهدون الاستيطان وهم يشاهدون
الحواجز وهم يشاهدون تكثيف العمليات
العسكريه في المدن الفلسطينيه همم
الانتهاكات اليوميه للمسجد الاقصى والكثير
من القضايا التي يعني يلمسها المواطن
يوميا يجعله يعني غير متفائل بتاتا باي
انفراج سياسي او اي هدوء همم قد يعوم
المنطقه في ظل همم الوضع الحالي القائم
وضع الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحالي
جزيلا لكن من رام الله مراسل العربيه عبد
الحفيظ جامعه
[موسيقى]
عن عقد قمه بين اوكرانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي في اكياف الجمعه فاوضح هاشميغالا
ان القمه ستكون غداه مشاورات حكوميه بين
اوكرانيا والمفوضيه الاوروبيه وستكون
الاولى في تاريخك
ان عقد هذه القمه في كياب يوجه رساله قويه
الى الشركاء والاعداء على حد سواء بحسب
تعبير فقال انه يتوقع من القمه تقيما
حاليا ايجابيا لجهود اوكرانيا لتحقيق
التكامل مع اوروبا
اقتربنا من هيئه عامر على اندلاع الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن نيرانها مازالت تشتغل اكثر
فاكثر مراسل العربيه افاد بان القوات
الروسيه هاجمت بلده ديلكو جنوب مدينه
ايضا بلده براس كوفيكا من المحور الشمالي
حول اطراف وسط عمليات اقتحام لبلده
ايفانوسكي بينما تدافع القوات الاوكرانيه
بهجمات مضاده من شمال
تحديدا مع قتال شوارع في مناطق مختلفه من
المحور الشمالي ومن سوريا
من الجانب الروسي ان القوات الاوكرانيه
انسحبت من خط الدفاع الاول هناك واضاف
وفقا معنى نقلته وكاله سبوتنيك الروسيه
ساخن بين الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني وهي
التي تضم اكبر محطه قويه في اوروبا
الانسحاب الاوكراني في زبوجيا دفع القوات
الاوكرانيه الى اعاده تم وضع حيث افاده
مراسل العربيه بان الجيش الاوكراني انشا
قواعد عسكريه جديده قريبه من نقاط تمركز
للقوات الروسيه التي سيطرت عليها مؤخرا في
منطقه كامزكي على الاتجاه الرئيسي من بلده
اريغفا لمدينه سابوريجيا تعزز القوات
الاوكرانيه القواعد باليات ومدافع ومنصات
صواريخ كمان نشاهد في هذه الصور لضربي
مناطق تابعه لروسيا في مقاطعه
المتحدث باسم السلاح الجو الاوكراني
يوريغنات في تصريحات صحفيه قال ان
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى ما يصل الى 200 طائره
متعدده الاغراض للدفاع عن اجوائها واضاف
اجناد ان بلاده تسعى الى استبدال الطائرات
السوفياتيه المتقدمه من انواع مختلفه بنوع
واحد من المقاتلات متعدده الاغراض
تعتبر ان اوكرانيا هي واحده من اكبر الدول
في اوروبا وتحتاج الى غطاء جوي في زمن
الحرب وفي وقت السمع في اطار الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا على نوازير الدفاع عن الرجيم
يورن ايرلد جرام ان بلاده ستنقل دبابات
لبورد 2 المانيه الصنع لاوكرانيا بنهايه
مارس الخادم فيما لم يحدد الوزير النرويجي
عددها الا ان بلاده تملك 36 دبابه من طراز
كانت المانيا اعلنت انها ستسمح للدول
الاخرى التي تمتلك هذه الدبابات بنقلها
الى اوكرانيا ايضا اما وزير الدفاع
الفرنسي سيباستيانو فاعلن ان باريس سترسل
12 مدفع عن اضافيا من طراز سيزر الى
اوكرانيا
وخلال لقاء مع نظيره الاوكراني في باريس
اضافنيو ان ارسال الطائرات المقاتله الى
اوكرانيا ليس من الممنوعات وان فرنسا
سترسل شهريا 150 عسكريا الى بولندا لتدريب
600 جندي اوكراني برر وزير الدفاع
الفرنسيه عدم ارسال دبابات الى اوكرانيا
بصعوبه صيانتها
وينضم الينا من باريس مراسل العربيه حسين
قنيبر اهلا بك حسين يعني كان هناك اليوم
مؤتمر صحفي بين وزيري الدفاع الاوكراني
وايضا الفرنسي ما ابرز ما اعلن خلال هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي
اهلا بك راويه وزميلنا طاهر ايضا في
الواقع انا ابدا من حيث انتهيت في تقديمك
للخبر عندما اتحدثت عن كلام فرنسي عن
صعوبه صيانه دبابات الثقيله نعم هذا واحد
من الاسباب التي تدفع فرنسا للتريق قبل
ارسال هذه الدبابات الى اوكرانيا لان ثمن
دبابات الواحده يبلغ 8 ملايين يورو لكن
صيانه هذه الدبابه نفقت صيانتها سنويا
تبلغ ربع مليون يورو هذا واحد من الاسباب
التي تدفع فرنسا الى التريث في ارشادها
بالعوده الى ما قاله وزيرا الدفاع الفرنسي
والاكرامي بيوم خلال معتمرهما الصحفي
المشترك اولا اعلن الوزير الفرنسي
السبستيان لقرن وزير الدفاع ان بلاده
ستقدم خلال الاسابيع المقبله اثني عشر
مدفع سيزار
ليه اوكرانيا كانت فرنسا قدمت سابقا ثم 18
مدفعا وضع احدها خارج الخدمه بعد اصابته
وسبعه عشر مدفعا الباقيه تحتاج الى صيانه
كما ان فرنسا كانت اتفقت مع الدنمارك على
ان تقدم هذه الاخيره 19 مدفع سيزار كانت
فرنسا باعتها سابقا الى الدنمارك اتفق على
ان تقدمها الدنمارك الى اوكرانيا وهكذا
يصبح العدد الاجمالي لمدافع سيجار التي
تمتلكها اوكرانيا بينما قدمته فرنسا سابقا
وما ستقدمه في الاسابيع المقبله وما قدمته
الدنمارك من مدافع فرنسيه من طراز سيزار
بالاتفاق مع فرنسا يبلغ العدد الاجمالي
تسعه واربعين مدفعا من طراز السيزار الذي
يبلغ مداه مدفع سيزار 40 كلم وهو يعني من
عيار
155 ملليمترا كما اتفق على ان تواصل فرنسا
التنسيق مع اوكرانيا لتعزيز عمليات تدريب
وتكوين للاوبرا يعنيين كي يتمكنوا من
استخدام المعدات الحربيه التي ترسلها
اليهم فرنسا ومن صيانتها في حال تعطلت
تركز ايضا وزير الدفاع الفرنسي على تقديم
الرادار من طراز جي ام 200 كانت اوكرانيا
طلبته رادار رصد وهي ستحصل عليه كما قال
سباستيانو بخصوص الموضوع المقاتلات الى اي
همم يعني مدى الموقف الفرنسي الثابت وواضح
في هذا المجال وهل هناك من همم بنود معينه
او شروط معينه او مخاوف
نعم ما تسميه بنودا او شروطا او مخاوف
طاهر سماه الرئيس الفرنسي معايير هو وضع
معايير ثلاثه لارسال دبابات لوكلار
الثقيله او لارسال طائرات مقاتله مع ان مع
ان فرضيه ارسال طائرات مقاتله من قبل
فرنسا اصبحت ضعيفه بعد ان اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي يوم امس ان بلاده لن ترسل طائرات
مقاتله الى اوكرانيا ويصعب تخيل ان ترسل
فرنسا طائرات مقاتله اذا قررت امريكا عدم
ارسال طائرات ممثله المعايير الثلاثه التي
وضعها مايكرون هي اولا ان لا تكون الخطوه
تصعيديه اذا ارسلت فرنسا دبابات ثقيله او
طائرات مقاتله بمعنى الا تستخدم هذه
الدبابات او الطائرات لغايه دفاعيه هجوميه
عفوا بل دفاعيه فقط والا تمس هذه المعدات
من دبابات و طائرات الاراضي الروسيه بل ان
تعزز فقط الجهد المقاوم لدى اوكرانيا
المعيار الثاني ان يكون ارسال هذه
الدبابات او طائرات مفيده بمع ان يصار الى
تكوين وتدريب الجنود الاوكرانيين على
استخدامها في حال ارسالها والمعيار الثالث
الا تقلل من القدرات الدفاعيه للجيش
الفرنسي لان المخزون العسكري الفرنسي كان
قضاء بعد الحرب البارده وخصوصا بعد العام
2007 عندما بدات فرنسا تتخلص من بعض
مخزونها العسكري اما بتفكيكه او ببيعه
لانها لم تكن تتخيل ان حربا ستندلع من
النوع الذي اندلع في اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا
لك حسين قنيبر مراسل العربيه من باريس على
كل هذه التفاصيل والمعلومات تحياتنا اليك
شكرا جزيلا
نشرت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه صورا لتدريب
اطقم الدبابات الاوكرانيه على دبابات
تشالنجر 2 والتي ستقدمها المملكه المتحده
لمساعده القوات الاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لا شك ان موازين القوه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه لم تبقى على حالها كما كان
عليه الحلقه عند بدايه الحرب الجيش الروسي
بات اليوم يواجه جيشا اوكرانيا وعززا
باسلحه غربيه متطوره ومتنوعه لكن السؤال
المطروح الان كيف يمكن ان تنتقل الكيف من
مرحله الدفاع الى مرحله البحث عن الانتصار
في الحرب سؤال طرحته مجله فرن فرز
الامريكيه التي حاولت تلخيص العوامل التي
قد تساعد اوكرانيا على حسم الحرب لصالحها
تقول المجله ان اهم خطوه يمكن ان يتخذها
حلفاء اوكرانيا هي تزويدها بالاسلحه التي
ستسمح لقوتها بشن هجمات على القوات
الروسيه واشارت المجله الى حاجه اوكرانيا
لمنظومات صواريخ طويله المدى مثل منظومه
الامريكيه البالغ مدى صواريخها 300 كلم
كما سيحتاج الجيش اوكراني الى قدرات جويه
هجوميه اقوى اقوى بكثير بما في ذلك طائرات
مقاتله واخرى بدون طيار
وشددت المجله على ضروره مواصله تشديد
العقوبات على موسكو بشكل كبير ومحاوله
تصنيف الاتحاد الروسي كدوله راعيه للارهاب
كما اكدت المجله على ان مواصله خفض سقف
اسعار صادرات النفط الروسيه سيضعف روسيا
بشكل كبير
تعاني مقاطعه دونات شح المياه منذ مطلع
العام الماضي تزامنا مع اندلاع الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث يتهم سكانها اوكرانيا بقطع
الماء عن تلك المناطق المواليه لروسيا
الجيش الروسي بكل قويه على المناطق
الشماليه في المقاطعه مثل مدينه مخمود
التي تحتاج المياه العذبه خلفها في نهر
منذ انطلاق الاعمال العسكريه والمواطنون
في مقاطعه دانيت يسعون لتقنين استخدام
المياه التي يصعب الحصول عليها وان كانت
غير صالحه للشرب
منذ حوالي نصف عام وهكذا نحصل على المياه
مره كل ثلاثه ايام
والمقاطعه باكملها بعد ان اصبح المياه
تضخوا ساعتين كل ثلاثه ايام
للمنطقه وليس للمنازل والبيوت هو مع دخول
فصل الشتاء اصبحت المياه واكثر شحا وباتت
الحاجه لحل ازمه المياه ملحه وسط سعي
السلطات المحليه لايصالها عبر انابيب من
نهر الدون في مدينه رستوف الروسيه الاقرب
اللي دانيت
تضخ المياه لساعات محدوده منذ شهر يوليو
والان يعملون على ايصال المياه لنا
عندما يحرر تلك المناطق فقط سوف تدخل لنا
المياه فنهرسيفسكي يمر
منسك ثم يصل الينا ويسعد جيش الروسي
للسيطره على المدن الشماليه من مقاطعه من
اجل الوصول الى مصادر المياه العذبه في
حوض دمباس خلف مدين باخموت وكرامه
والتي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني ما
زالت المياه شحيحه في مقاطعه ذلك بعد منع
امداداتها من قبل القوات الروسيه التي
تسيطر على مدينه سلافيانسك في المنطقه
الشماليه من المقاطعه بينما تحوي هذه
المدينه ابرر تحليه المياه القائمه على
نهر سيفر دانيت لقناتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاخضر
في فرنسا اضراب واشتباكات التظاهرات ضد
نظام التقاعد تتحول الى صدامات بين الشرطه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
هذه المره جاء الدور على رجال الدين
ليدخلوا دائره الملاحقه من طرف رجال الامن
الحديث هنا يخص تحديدا مناطق كردستان في
غرب البلاد وبلوشستان في الجنوب الشرقيه
واللتين تشهدان استمرار المظاهرات
والاحتجاجات السلطات الايرانيه دخلت على
الخط محاوله الاحتجاجات من خلال الضغط على
رجال الدين السنه والسعي لارغامهم على
التعاون معها بهذا الخصوص افادت تقارير
وارده من ايران عن اعتقال مولوي عبد
المجيد مراد زهي وهو مستشار وعضو مكتب
مولوي عبد الحميد اسماعيل زاهي الزعيم
الرحيل بلوشي الذي يمتلك شعبيه كبيره في
منطقه بلوشستان كما تم اعتقال اثنين من
رجال الدين السنه المؤيدين للاحتجاجات في
اقليم كردستان ووافقه تقارير الوارده فان
السلطات الايرانيه تبرر هذه الاعت
بالتشويش على الراي العام واجراء اتصالات
عديده مع وسائل الاعلام اجنبيه فضلا عن
تحريف الراي العام وكان مولوي عبد المجيد
مراد زهير قد اكد في مقابله مع اذاعه
امريكيه ناطقه بالفارسيه ان التشديدات
الامنيات تسود في زهدان عاصمه بروشستان كم
انتقد تعيين احمد رضا ردان قائدا للقوات
الشرطه الايرانيه التي يرى انها تبث الذره
والرعبه في البلاد هذه الاعتقالات التي
شملت رجال دين لم تجد المحتجين كما نشاهد
في هذه الصور الى غضبا
هيتخرج عدد من الاهالي الى الشارع احتجاجا
على الاعتقالات ومرددين الشعارات ضد
النظام كما اشعل وراينا النيران في
الشوارع شكرا راويه بالفعل تطورات ما يحدث
في الداخل الايرانيه عكس او تنعكس خارجا
ونتحدث هنا على الصعيد الدولي ولكن قبل ان
نذكر بما جاء على لسان الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي قبل قليل في احدى المقابلات
وهو يتحدث عن الاحتجاجات في بلاده يصفها
بالاضطرابات ويحملها مسؤوليه تدهور الوضع
الاقتصادي وندره الدولار على الصعيد
الدولي فان طهران بدات منزعجه اذا
التطورات المتلاحقه والتحذيرات التي
تصيلها من جهات مختلفه اخرها من القدس حيث
اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لوزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي على ضروره مواجهه ايران كما
تحدث
برساله واضحه لخصوم اسرائيل
يوه يا بيزيد زيارتك في وقت حرج وهي تبعث
رساله واضحه لخصومنا وكذلك لشركائنا في
المنطقه الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
المتحده في ضروره مواجهه ايران وكل من
يهدد السلامه والاستقرار
سبق هذا التصريح تصريحات بالامس للمبعوث
الامريكي الخاص الى طهران روبرت مالي الذي
قال انه واشنطن لن تتردد باتخاري اي خطوه
لوقف سلوك ايران العدواني اذا فشل الحوار
كما اضاف روبرت مالي الخيار العسكري مع
ايران مطروح اذا فشل الحلوا الدبلوماسيه
ردت ايران
لدى الامم المتحده المحذره من ان اي عمل
عسكري امريكي ضد ايران سيؤدي الى صراع
واسع النطاق وسيح يحمي العواقب على منطقه
الشرق الاوسط باكملها قالت البعثه لصحيفه
نيوز ويك انها لا تزال ترى هذا الاحتمال
ضعيفا محضره في الوقت نفسه واشنطن منشن اي
حرب على طهران في المستقبل وتاتي هذه
التصريحات على خلفيات الهجمه الاخيره التي
نفذتها اسرائيل في ايران واستهدفت من
خلالها منشاه تابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه في اصفها
واشنطن لم تتاخر في الرد على التلميحات
الايرانيه بامكانيه ضلوعها في العمليه
الاسرائيليه الاخيره مصدر في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لم يذكر اسمه اكد لنزويك ان
القوات العسكريه الامريكيه لم تقم بشن اي
ضربات او عمليات في ايران واوضح في الوقت
نفسه ان الولايات المتحده تواصل مراقبه
الوضع وانها لم تتدخل في الهجوم الذي وقع
نهايه الاسبوع على ايران كانت هذه الهجمات
قد اثارت حفيظه طهران التي توعدت اسرائيل
بالرد
ينضم الينا الان من واشنطن حسين عبد
الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات اهلا بك معنا مره جديده
استاذ حسين في العربيه 360 اين ترى نقاط
التماهي ونقاط الاختلاف بين الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه
واسرائيل بحكومتها الحاليه اليمنيه
المتشدده في ما يتعلق بايران وهل يمكن ان
يتغير الموقف على وقع الضغوط الاسرائيليه
مساء الخير طاهر اعتقد انه الموقف
الاسرائيلي هو نفسه بغض النظر عن اي حكومه
كان على هذا الشكل في زمن نتنياه ثم لافيد
ثم نتنياهو مجددا والموقف الاسرائيلي
الارجح انه همم يعني ترسمه المؤسسه
العسكريه والمؤسسات الامنيه ولا يرتبط
كثيرا بالتغييرات السياسيه اما الموقف
الامريكي فهو على عكس اسرائيل
بمن يشغل البيت الابيض وهو في زمن الرئيس
ترامب كان اكثر تشددا تجاه ايران طبعا
انسحب من الاتفاقيه النوويه شدد العقوبات
قام بتصفيه قاسم سليماني
وبناء عليه لم يعني لم تقم ايران لا
بتقسيم اليورانيوم في عمليات استفزازيه
ولكن همم اليوم مع معتقد انه الولايات
المتحده متراخي وهذا ما يخلق تباين بين
الولايات المتحده واس
وبالتالي سيد حسين يعني مرد الايراني
المتوقع بعد ما هدد هددت طهران
وما الاوراق اصلا التي تمتلكها
طبعا الرد الايراني هو يعني ايران ترغب في
المواجهات غير التقليديه ايران لا ترغب في
المواجهات يعني
جيش تقليد جيش تقليدي هي تفضل المواجهات
يعني اما عن طريق الارهاب او عن طريق
الميليشيات او عن طريق يعني الاعمال
الخفيه ولا يناسب ايران ان تطورت الامور
الى يعني حرب مواجهه بين الولايات المتحده
وايران بشكل مباشر ولذلك اعتقد انه ايران
فقط يعني تقوم بتصريحات من باب التهويل
ولكن يعني على عكس ما يرى البعض لا توجد
حرب عالميه ثانيه لا قدره لايران اصلا على
علشان او على التصدي لاي من هذه الحروب
اعتقد انه ايران منهمكه حاليا في قمع
الايرانيين في الداخل من جهه ومن جهه
ثانيه منشغله بعمليه تطوير والتوصل الى
صناعه قنبله او او اكثر يعني سلاح نووي
بشكل عام وين فينا نحط الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه في كل بين كل الملفات التي
بايران بعلاقتها بامريكا واسرائيل في ما
يتعلق بضربه عسكريه بحرب من عدم ذلك اي
اين يمكن ان نضع هذا الملف بين الملفات
الاخرى
اسرائيل حاولت ان يعني
تتبنى نوع من الحياد لانه لا تريد ان توتر
العلاقه مع روسيا لانه لديها ملفات عالقه
خصوصا على الحدود مع سوريا وما الى هنالك
اما الولايات المتحده في من الواضح انها
تدعم اوكرانيا بشكل كامل تسليح ودعم
وتدريب ودعم مالي واقتصادي وكذلك الدول
الغربيه في اوروبا ايران ربما رات في ذلك
فرصه لتشكيل
تحالف المناول للغرب الذي يعني يبشر به
منذ سنوات وهو تحالف ايضا يبشر به فوتو
واعتقد انه هذا ما ادى الى التوصل الى
جبهه شبه مشتركه بين جانبه طيب سيد حسين
باختصار لو سمحت اتحقيقات الايرانيه ساريه
الان همم بيحاول من الجهه التي استهدفت
ولكن اصابع الاتهام بطبيعه الحال ذهبت
اولا الى اسرائيل ولكن هل الجهه
الاوكرانيه هل اوكرانيا ربما تدخل
بان تكون احدى السيناريوهات التي يمكن ان
تنفذ هكذا عمليه لانه كلنا نتذكر تغريده
همم
المستشار مستشار الرئاسه ميخائيل بدويات
اعتقد انه اوكرانيا منشغله بما هو يعني
اهم من ذلك الدفاع عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه
في وجه الروس طبعا التغريده كانت من باب
المناكفه لعلم الاوكران انه ايران تقوم
ببيع وتزويد روسيا بطائرات درون من دون
طيار ولكن عدا ذلك اعتقد انه يعني حسب ما
ورد في صحيح في صحيفه جانا لانه الاصابع
تشير الى اسرائيل واعتقد انه ايران تعرف
انها اسرائيل ولكن ايران من ناحيه تحاول
تظاهر بانها قادره على الرد ولكنها حياه
ثانيه تحاول تسطر على ذلك لعلمها انه ليس
بعد هذا طبعا هي ما تزال تعمل على
الانتقام لمقتل قاتل لمقتل سليمان بمحاوله
تصفيه امريكيه ولكن هذا لم يحصل حتى الان
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ حسين عبد الحسين
البحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
واشنطن تحياتنا اليك
وقفي العربيه 360 ايضا كبسوله مشعه مفقوده
في استراليا وحاله تاهب للعطور عليها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اهلا بكم اذا جبها جديد
قد تفتح في وجه الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب هذه المره الداخله الحزب
الجمهوريه
من داخل الحزب الجمهوري والحديث هنا عن
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا جراند سليمان
وبعيدا عن الصراع بين الطرفين فان ترشح
ديسانتس في حال تم يبدو مزعجا نوعا
بالنسبه الى ترامب وذلك لعده اعتبارات
اولها يا طاهر ان صوره ترامب تضررت بشكل
او باخر بالاداء المخيبه للامال
للجمهورينا في الانتخابات النصفيه وذلك
بسبب الاسماء التي راهن عليها ودعمها على
العكس من ذلك فان ديسان نجح في الحفاظ على
مقعده مره اخرى في فلوريدا وهي الولايه
التي كان فيها اداء جمهوريين جيدا بشكل
عام وبلغه استطلاعات الراي فان الفجوه
ليست كبيره بين ديسانتس وترامب حيث ذكر
استطلاع حديث اجراه مركز ان ديسانس تحسن
في مواجهه ترامب حيث حصل على 28% من
التاييد مقابل 46% للترم بنسبه انخفاض
وصلت الى 11% ويعتبر ترامب المرشح الوحيد
الذي اطلق رسميا ترشحه لسباق 20 24 لكن
العديد من الجمهوريين اشاروا الى انهم
يفكرون في الترشح بما في ذلك او بمن في
ذلك نائب رئيس السابق مايك بانس وسفير
الامريكيه السابقه لدى الامم المتحده نيكي
هيلي وزير الخارجيه السابق مايك بومبيو
قال تقرير صادر عن مكتب الولايات المتحده
للتجاره ان الصين تتصدر العالم في
المنتجات المقلده والمقرصنه واعتبرت
الممثله التجاريه للولايات المتحده ان
تطبيق ويتشات لدردشه الاكثر شعبيه في
الصين واحد من اكبر منصات للسلعه المقلده
واشار تقرير الى ان السلعه المقلده
والمقارنه من الصين مع البضائع المنقوله
منها الى هونغ كونغ تمثل 75% من قيمه
السلعه المقلده والمقارنه التي صدرتها
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
محمد القناص الحمد لله على السلامه
الجمعيه العموميه العاديه الثالث
والثلاثين الاتحاد الاسيوي لكره القدم
الذي سيشهدوا علينا فوز سلمان بن ابراهيم
ال خليفه بفتره الولايه الثالثه برئاسه
الاتحاد القاري بالتزكيه كما سيتم ايضا
اجراء انتخابات المكتب التنفيذي وممثلي
القاره او ممثلين عفوا القاره الاسيويه
لعضويه مجلس فيفا وسيتم كذلك اختيار البلد
المنظم لكاس اسيا 2017 مع بقائي ملف وحيد
وهو ملف السعوديه والتي تسعى لتنظيم
البطوله لاول مره
تنطلق قوه الاربعاء منافسات كاس العالم
للانديه التي تستضيفها المغرب ويخوض
الاهلي المصري وصيفو بطل افريقيا البطوله
التي يشارك فيها للمره الثالثه على
التوالي مباراه الدور الاول امام وكلن
النيوزلندي بطل للقياسيا وذلك في استاد بن
بطوطه في مدينه طنجه الفائز من المباراه
سيقابل سياسي الامريكي في ربع النهائي
اعلان ريال مدريد حامل لقب الدوري
الاسباني يعني اصابته لاعبيها الفرنسي
كشف بيان النادي بعد الفحوصات التي خضع
لها مندي عن تشخيصي اصابته في عضله الساق
اليسرى وسيخضع لفتره تاهيل قد تستمر شهرين
في اليوم الاخير لنافذه انتقالات اللاعبين
الشتويه اكمل نادي ارسنال الاجراءات
انتقال لاعبي خط الوسط جورجيني قادما من
تشيلسي في صفقه قدرت ب 12 مليون جنيه
استرليني لمده عام ونصف وذلك لدعم صفوف
الفريق في صراعه على لقب الدوري الانجليزي
كان ارسنال اعلنها خضوعها لاعبه محمد
النني لجراحه في الركبه قد تبعثه حتى
نهايه الموسم
بدوره اكد نادي مانشستر يونايتد عن غياب
لاعبه الدنماركي حتى نهايه ابريل بعد
التعرضه للاصابه
وفي المانيا اعلن بايرن ميونخ ضم الظهير
البرتغالي وكنسلو من مانشستر سيتي على
سبيل الاعاره مع امكانيه ضمه بشكل نهائي
صيفا
وفي مصر يغلق الليله باب سوق الانتقالات
الشتويه للانديه المصريه ابرز صفقات في
تغيير
الاهلي الذي يسعى الى الحفاظ على صداره
الدوري وينتظره منافسات دوري الابطال
تعاقد مع اربع صفقات في مراكز مختلفه
والبدايه بجناح النجم الساحلي محمد الضو
كريستو ثم لاعب خط وسط الاتحاد السكندري
مروان عطيه ومدافع سموحه خالد عبد الفتاح
واخيرا لاعب خط وسط وفاق سطيف الجزائري
احمد قندوسي
محتاج البنك بعد الاصابه اكثر من توفي
وكريم فؤاد برباط الصليبي ما بقاش عنده
غير محمد ثاني فقط لا غير في الجانب
اليمين لا قدر يجيب خالد همم عبد الفتاح
من سموحه حتى لو سبيل العار بس عنده نيه
الشباب في نهايه الموسم بشكل كويس في فتره
الصيف يعني لما خسر الدوري وكان خسرنا
الكاس اللي قبلها وخسران بطوله افريقيا
يمكن الجمهور الاهلي كان نتكلم على ان ده
موسم صفر النادي الاهلي فلما يبدا الموسم
الجديد المفترض يمكن يبقى عنده همم مجموعه
من التعاقدات لكن ده الاهلي ما عملتش
تعاقدات عمل عمل مصطفى سعد عمل همم
شادي حسين مش اكثر من كده كلهم مع كامل
التقدير والناس كلهم طبعا شايفينهم يعني
عاديين وفي الزمالك بورصه التعاقدات ان لم
تشهد توسعا في ضم الصفقات الجديده رغم عدم
ظهور الصفقات الصيفيه على قدر التوقعات
ليكتفي الفارس الابيض بالتعاقد لمده خمس
مواسم مع المهاجم ناصر منسي القادم من
نادي البنك الاهلي والمغربي احمد بلحاج
لاعب فريق اسوان لمده سته اشهر على سبيل
الاعاره ومحمد كناريا لاعب نادي سيراميكا
هم محتاجين همم انه يبقى في هدوء بشكل نسب
في كل حاجه ما يبقاش في مشاكل وما يبقاش
في الصراعات هنشوف الزمالك بشكل احسن لكن
انا شايف ان الزمالك لسه قدامه الموسم
بدري ان هو يقدر يلحق همم في بطوله الدوري
في دوري ابطال افريقيا مطلوب منه ما يحسن
كل ماتشات
الكبيره عن باقي الانبياء والمصريه في
يناير
اختفت باعاره لاعبين فيما بينها وابرام
تعاقدات فيما بينها بعيدا عن اي صفقات
للاعبين اجانب جدد نرمين سامي العربيه
القاهره
هذه كانت ابرز اخبار الرياضه عوده الان
الى طاهر لاستكمال العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا محمد كبسوله مفقوده تثير الذعر في
استراليا والسبب ان هذه الكبسوله نوويه
وكاله سلمى نوويه الاستراليه اعلنت ارسال
فريق متخصص للبحث عن كبسوله مشعه مفقوده
منذ اسبوع
ونقلا عن السلطات الاستراليه فان الكبسوله
ربما سقطت في ولايه استراليه غربيه وهو
الحادث الذي دفع السلطات الى الاعلان عن
وجود خطر اشعاعي في اجزاء كبيره من هذه
الولايه ونقلا عن مسؤولين في قطاع الصحفي
ولايه استراليا الغربيه فان الكبسوله اذا
بقيت بالقرب من الجسم قد تتسبب في احمرار
الجلد وحروق اشعاعيه كما يمكن ان تؤثر في
جهاز المناعه
[موسيقى]
انا وزير الدفاع الامريكيه الولد اصلا انا
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه باستخدام الاسلحه
التقليديه والنوويه للردعي والدفاع عن
كوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده مستعده للدفاع عن كوريا
الجنوبيه من انشطه كوريا الشماليه
وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي يزور سور للمره
الثالثه بصفته وزيرا للدفاع
التزامنا بحمايه جمهوريه كوريا
الذي يتضمن استخدام مجموعه كامله من
الوسائل العسكريه الامريكيه بمفي ذلك
الاسلحه التقليديه النوويه وكذلك الدفاع
الصاروخي
الوزير الامريكي في مؤتمر المشترك مع
نظيره الكوري الجنوبي اشار الى ان كوريا
الشماليه ارتكبت عام 2022 عدا غير مسبوق
من الاستفزازات موضحا ان امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبيه تدين ما وصفه بالاجراءات الخطيره
التي تزعم استقرار الوضع في المنطقه
ومؤكدا ان التدريبات العسكريه المقبله بين
البلدين تهدف لضمان ان يقابل الحلفاء
التهديدات النوويه الكوريه الشماليه
وهو ما تحدث عنه وزير الدفاع كوريا
الجنوبيه كذلك
مؤكدامهما بتعزيز التعاون الثلاثي مع
اليابان ايضا
حقيب اللقاء كشف بيان المشترك لبنتغون عن
اتفاق بتوسيع نطاق التدريبات المشتركه بين
البلدين هذا العامه
لوزير الدفاع الامريكي بعنوان التحالف
ويقف على اهبه الاستعداد قال فيه ان
واشنطن وصول ستجريان منورات تحاكي
سيناريوهات معقده تركز على التهديدات
النوويه في شبه جزيره الكوريه ملوك الشيخ
العربيه
[موسيقى]
شهدت العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس اشتباكات بين
رجال الامن ومئات الالاف من المحتاجين ضد
النظام التقاعد وتقدم المسيره رؤساء
النقابات الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]
الحاله لم يكن افضل في بريطانيا حيث ينظم
المعلمين في جميع انحاء بريطانيا اضرابا
غدا بعد عقد من الارباح الضائره في نظام
المدرسيه تموله الدوله
بالكامل من قبل الحكومه
المعلمين بشغل وظائف الثاني
اذا كان بامكاني جاني وما يكفي من المال
وعدم الاضطرار الى القيام بالدروس
الخصوصيه في المساء
فلاحياه اكثر سعاده الراتب لا يشد الحاجه
حتى الاخر من الشهر والتوتر الذي يسببه لا
يصدق على الاطلاق هناك مره افكر من اين
سياتي المال كل شهر بمثابه
كبيره كما تعلم لدينا الكثير من المعلمين
الذين تركوا المهنه لمجرد انهم محرومون من
حقوقهم لقد سائم من الطريقه التي تسير بها
الامور انستغرام
[موسيقى]
مصائب قوم عند قوم فوائده ففي الوقت الذي
يتم فيه تصريح عشرات الاف الموظفين في
وادي السلكوم بولايه كاليفورنيا تجد شركات
المانيه فرصه لاستقطاب وتوظيف هذه المواهب
خاصه في ظل ما تواجهه من شحن في سوق العمل
ونقص العماله من ذوي المهارات الاساسيه في
هندسه البرمجيات وقالت مجموعه بيتكم وهي
جمعيه رقميه في المانيا تضم اكثر من 2000
شركه في الاقتصاد الرقمي قالت ان لدى
المانيا
137,000 وظيفه شاغره في مجال التكنولوجيا
المعلومات
الهجره وتروج الاحتمال الحصول على الجنسيه
بسهوله لاغراء المهاجرين المهاره المحتمله
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من افغانستان
لا متناهل وفي قلبها نار لفراق ابنها
وموته بردان
الذي مات بسبب البرد اشعل موته نارا في
قلبها ولا عزاء لها سوى ابنها الذي تحتضنه
خوفا من فراق جديد
متوفره في المراه مقيده بامر من طلبان‬»
اصبح متطرفه
الى تصريح اليوم تصريح اليوم ما هو لرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الذي صرح
بناء مشاركته لما قال عن المسؤول السابق
في مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه شارل
ماجنوجل وهذا التصريح جاء في منشور على
موقع الاجتماعي الخاص بك حيث اشار الى
التعليقات التي ادلى بها بعد اجتماعه مع
بوتين 2018 عندما قال انه لا يرى اي سبب
لتدخل روسيا في انتخابات عام 2016 على
الرغم مما افاد به مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرا
لاف بي اي وصرح ترامب انه يثق في بوتين
اكثر من اصحاب الهمم الواهنه ممن يعملون
في الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
فيديو اليوم من باكستان فما كان بالامس
مسجدا اصبح اليوم ركاما مجبولا بالدماء
التفجير الدموي في المنطقه الحمراء تخطى
كل الحواج لتصبح حمراء فعلا
تفجير في مدينه بيشاور ارتفعت الى مئه شخص
[موسيقى]
يمكن ان تتراوح بين عشره و 12 كلغ لم يكن
الضرر الكبير بسبب المتفجره لكن بسبب
موجات الصدمر الانفجار انهار سقف المسجد
وعلق الناس تحت الانقاض كان هناك ثلاثه
اشخاص عالقين تحت العوارض الخرسانيه
وعندما انهار السقف سقط على الارض ما تسبب
في اضرار جسيمه
هكذا نصل الى ختام العربيه 360 من العربيه
ولكن اخبار الساعه لا تنقطع وتستمر مع
الزميل
مره اخرى واهلا به مره اخرى ههه اهلا في
اخبار الساعه طبعا بعد قليل المزيد من
الملفات وفي صداره اخبار الساعه طبعا
التسليح الغربي لاوكرانيا سنكون مع شبكه
مراسلين في اوروبا و روسيا والولايات
المتحده
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]